có tổ rên này sau rời là bố đi mẫu về thì ta trở hiền dà trong tận đá lòng của mình nghĩ rằng
đẹp là khỏi era, chiều không phải đẹp là bất tập sự khỏi era.
Đẹp cho loa ăn gặm đất là hoa đẹp, nhưng mà phải khỏi era,
tởi vì khi mình đẹp mình đi, thì có sự bình như cái gì chuyện,
mình chỉ nằm bị giữ vệnh hoa hi đẹp chai xem.
Bây giờ mình thay đổi ở 1 liệu phá là xấu sản,
mình bây giờ đứng hướng, tế những cái phương pháp, làm đẹp.
Mà phải xấu từ mình trong ràng hoa, chều có những phương pháp hiểu xưa mà
sỏi thế, lýng tục nữa, về giờ thì tháo là ăn ống rất là đúng bữa luôn đó,
ăn đúng giờ là phép ăn, phía là về tí táu tạo rời,
mình không thể đợi nhìn nở, kươi hai tinh rối,
bà tính là bắt của phép cóm cái gì đó, chào gặp bộm.
Tất là cái là vui bản, và vảyêu thái,
và thêm là vui vụ mình không có tối mật nè,
mình sẽ không tìm được thứ quá nhiều vều mở,
cho nên là ăn đồ, mở chi đều, đồ vì bởi nhau,
là mình là ăn mà mình bỏ đi, rồi gáng của mình là phải là việc thái cho mật,
nó rất là bất bảo rời cho nên những tất cả mạnh mắm,
phay là vui, những cái tất cả mạnh mắm,
là người ta phải hạm nhiều hơn cho mình có hạnh chế,
mình sẽ phải nghe câu,
trong lý trả một cái trên sách làm cái gì được ăn cái gì,
hầm mình ăn cái gì, nó thánh chế đi,
phải sống theo đó, hẹn đo cuộc thôi bảo ăn,
nhưng mà mình mắn được thảo của bán là một người thích ăn ố,
thảo tất tự thích gì ngon cho không qua nhiều,
cho nó có hôm nay thử gì mới.